this is Joo underground podcast number
85 sitting here with Echo Charles and I
hope
that
people can accept
reality and what makes
this necessary in life is you can't
really make a plan or move in the right
direction if you can't accept reality of
what's happening and if you talk to
other human beings on a regular basis
you're going to see times where they do
not accept reality and it is the root
one of the roots of the problems that
they're having in their life look and
this happens in all it can happen in all
aspects of the world happens in combat
where guys will ignore Intel that's
coming in in or they'll ignore what the
enemy is doing they'll ignore
significant gunfire because they doesn't
fit with what they were
wanting so they don't accept reality
happens in business where where people
are looking at the market data they're
watching what the you know some obvious
move that the competitor is
making that they clearly it's going to
have an impact on their
business but they don't they don't
accept that as reality they
deny what's actually
happening so I think and I think it's a
good thing to focus on focus on
accepting reality just focus on that
it's a good thing to focus on there's
the thing it's it's hard
than you think it's going to be to
accept what reality is and that's
because the reality that you think is
what you think is
reality you see the little trick here
the little conundrum that we end up in
yeah you the reason you think it's
reality because you think it's reality
it's the freaking Truman Show is that
what it is The Truman Show he thinks
that's real he until he realizes it's
not until he sees the little hole he
thinks it's real yeah and and that's
where you might be in combat that's
where you might be in business that's
where you might be in relationship you
ever seen this is a real obvious one you
know some guys going out with a girl
yeah hell yeah and clearly to all
parties this girl is not doing right by
him maybe she's cheating on him maybe
she's treating him disrespectful there's
all kinds of things she could be doing
wrong and he doesn't see this as a
reality yeah he's not dealing with
reality
so there's a decent chance that whatever
you think is reality is
not you are lying to yourself or and by
the way you don't have to be actively
lying to yourself you don't have to
actively be lying to
yourself you just might not see
reality I mean imagine someone that is
colorblind and they've never known it
right like you get people that want to
join the military and they go to take
the screening test test and they failed
the color blindness
test and they don't understand what's
wrong they didn't know that there was
other colors out there they didn't know
that red and green were two distinct and
separate colors they didn't know that to
them it kind of looked the same or
someone that's nearsighted or someone
that's farsighted you seen the videos
that they got now the little uh uh I
guess they're not even clickbait they're
just they're just they're just algorithm
magnets where they like put glasses on a
little kid for the first time and they
can see their mom's face right that real
they didn't think that that wasn't
reality they thought that was
reality so that can happen to us where
we just we just can't see we don't we're
nearsighted or we're farsighted we're
colorblind so we we have to pay
attention to that and in order to
overcome that what we have to do is open
up our
minds we have to open up our minds you
have to open up your minds which is not
easy because Nature has has trained you
genetically and biologically to close
your mind that's what nature that's what
the world that's what your instincts
want you to your instincts want you to
close your mind because when you close
your mind you're
safe when you close your mind you're
secure when you close your mind you're
protected when you close your mind you
have control over what's happening and
you learn that at a young age and you
learn it over and over and over again
that there's risk to the open mind that
there's new ideas that there's ideas
that are contrary to what you've
thought that there's
danger
so on a shortterm level the open mind is
harder because it's so much easier just
to close the mind that's why tactically
speaking we close our
minds and it's and it seems like it's
better we seem like we win that tactical
War when we just close our minds when
the first time that someone had that had
been studying karate for 24 years and
just got Tapped Out by a blue belt in
Jiu-Jitsu the easiest thing to do was
just to close the mind and say yeah but
I'm never going to the ground or yeah
but that's not many people yeah but it
takes forever there was the easiest
thing to do is close that off protect
the ego short term the hardest thing to
do is oh there's something that I don't
know that I need to learn I need to get
on that path that's the open mind
mhm the closed mind in Jiu-Jitsu is 20
years ago oh foot locks are
disrespectful right yeah those aren't
real attacks that's a closed-minded
attitude instead of like oh I just got
Tapped Out by someone that did something
to my leg I should figure out what that
is that's what happened with John Doner
right he sees that Dean
Lis y he sees Dean lis
getting people to tap by doing something
to their feet doing something to their
knees doing something to their
heels and John Doner instead of saying
oh we need to compete in tournaments
where there's no foot locks no leg locks
instead it's oh this is a part of the
game that I did not understand I need to
open my
mind so it is a fight to keep your mind
open you have to pry your mind mind open
and you have to keep it open why because
in the long term in the Strategic the
open mind is more adaptive and the
Adaptive creature survives long
term longer than a strong one look it's
it's it's it's stronger move shortterm
to close my mind it allows me to power
through things MH but the
longterm the
strong things that can adapt will lose
it's the same thing with ideas you can
have a really strong idea but if you
don't adapt that idea over time it's end
up going it's going to end up being a
losing
idea adaptation means survival
open-mindedness means
adaptation so that's what we need to do
pry our minds open and keep them open so
that we can
see reality for what it really is or at
least as close to reality as you can
possibly
get and if you do that if you open your
mind you'll be able to see reality and
then you can make a plan you can move in
the right
direction so there you go yeah you
really want to do that CU there's a uh
so the expression reality check yeah
reality check reality check is
essentially when and I'm not educating
you proba you know that's obviously but
it's it's one of those things it comes
from if you're not in touch with reality
as much and then you're forced to be in
touch with reality all at once one big
thing that's a reality Che we support
reality checks oh yeah when needed
that's how but look if you're the
receiver you'd rather be in touch the
whole time so you don't suffer those
checks you don't want the check those
checks kind of suck from time to time I
mean they're useful but you know what's
more useful being in touch with reality
the whole time keeping an open mind all
the time yeah not having your mind get
opened up yeah forcefully or whatever
forcefully yes by a reality check yeah
yeah good point good point all right
let's get some
Quest that is a little excerpt of what
we are doing on the Joo underground
podcast so if you want to continue to
listen go to Joo underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us strengthen this
Legion of Troopers that are in the game
with us so thank you it's Joo
underground.com it costs
$818 a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance atjo underground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then we will see you
mobilized
Underground